ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show what's going on with Brendan
Schaub and Bobby Lee
uh well what's happening well I saw
Bobby and kalila went on h3h3
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's going on
uh looks like there's uh some
accusations what's happening
what's the 4-1-1
what's the deal
uh they're they're in a fight they're in
a feud right now why uh some accusations
are being thrown at Brandon who done it
why when where
what's going on
uh the podcast Community is uh flipped
upside down right now over uh actually
[ __ ] Wild
but I want to get some straight answers
how can I do my job how can I continue
to do my job without getting to the
bottom
is this why they're overturning Roe v
Wade
because of kalila Annie Letterman
Brandon Schaub Bobby Lee
Roe v Wade
what's going on Amy Coney Barrett
Chief Justice John Roberts Bobby Lee
Brandon Schaub kalila
Joe Biden the economy Jews Catholics
Protestants Muslims Bobby Lee
h3h3
can you get some [ __ ] answers yeah
yeah so uh it's your job people on the
internet are saying he's a bully why I
think he's made inappropriate passes at
women I mean to be specific here on the
Pod would feel unfair constitutes a
woman
freely
no I mean it's a real question in this
case a lady with a [ __ ] and titties
well I don't want you to start being
vulgar I don't think that's your job to
start being vulgar right now we're
talking about a serious issue I want you
to really kind of like
you know you're at work half the time
with you you know you forget you're at
work you can't start throwing out
vulgarities this isn't a blue show we
don't work blue here I apologize this is
a news show and the news I'm covering is
Bobby Lee Brandon Schaub Annie Letterman
kalila Esther povitzky
Roe v Wade
what's going on I have a clip here a
viral clip here of Bobby Lee exposing
Brendan Schaub and his goons for the
bullies they are of course wait
Brendan's job has goons yeah yeah there
are goons I think there are goons
involved
I'm let me tell you right now folks I
just went
to the rainforest to this hotel which
I'm I'm really
gonna I mean I you know
I I I'm I'm not gonna listen
I'm just gonna really let people know
what the problem and and
I mean plural problems are here there
are many
and it's unfortunate because I spent a
lot of money for this
um and I'm unhappy
and I'm I'm well within my rights to be
unhappy
um but I'm
trying and there are
indigenous tribes
all over this area
it's the world's oldest rainforest it's
180 million years old
and you see them you see these people
and I'm running up to them and going
what the [ __ ] is going on with Bobby Lee
and kalila and they're pretending they
don't know
they don't speak English
and I'm going do you understand what's
happening with Annie Letterman and I
don't know what they're doing
gathering fruit it's not my
business but I've been spending all of
my time here
trying to tell them
about this thing and I don't even know
what it is
I feel so disconnected
so what's going on again there are Goons
I think we should Brandon shab's got a
pirate ship of goons and they're going
after Bobby Lee is it because he's
Korean
is he Korean I don't think it's a race
thing but he is Korean yeah right well I
was right about that I do know some
things but I feel so out of everything I
don't feel included anymore
I'm like on the outside I'm a victim of
my own success
it's very hard to stay
connected to the issues of the day when
I'm out here in the rainforest trying to
lead these people to Christ now
play this clip of uh Bobby Lee I cannot
cover this folks many people don't want
me to cover it
right right people don't want me to
cover it but I have to cover it because
it's the news
this is big news
the point is now my fear is the the
results of whatever this is now going to
be there's no results because there is
there is a result
I can call shop right now and we could
be like all is squared away and
everything is fine because we've already
talked about it the promise was that he
would never talk about it again and the
next day he went on flagrant two and
then talked about it even though it was
in a complimentary way yeah in a
complimentary way I feel like we've said
anything bad about him either the point
is did was there
um was there a text
alluding to possibly suing people yes
there was that it did it freak me out
and did it make me think oh [ __ ] like
such a small thing to Silver but was
there a lot of misunderstanding from his
team and US yeah but we talked it
through but the truth is the truth
and you know it's all squared away so
you guys are just going to get this
clear so you guys were talking about
there was this comedian that people
assumed was him yeah that was trying to
pick up all you girls kind of a sleeves
whatever right
so he calls you
and says Bobby
get yours get your woman in line I mean
what kind of [ __ ] animal does that
that's [ __ ] up why didn't you call you
he has your number right I would assume
it's your [ __ ] podcast who the [ __ ]
why what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] it was
not just him
there's a whole barrage it was it was oh
don't say the name I'm not gonna but it
was a phone call with other podcasters
and it was uh some [ __ ] they flogged
you bro not flogged me they threatened
my career
they called me a coward a [ __ ] you've
always been a [ __ ]
and and um they said they would expose
me they said that all these things and I
was in Oklahoma shooting a show and I
was at dinner and I was by myself and I
was getting it was very traumatic for me
and it was based on whatever they did on
the live now imagine now what's going to
happen with now this it's good you said
that I think it's good that you're
saying
who are they
this is my question
he said it's a bunch of goods
well it's in I think it's implied right
they don't name them specifically but
it's implied the the people he kind of
hangs out with in the podcast world
oh
well
man did I miss this Scandal
I missed it
I feel bad
Brendan has always been very nice to me
my experiences with him are
overwhelmingly positive I should note
and I don't think this will be a
surprise to anyone and it won't be a
surprise to Brendan
Brandon is not the heir to Richard Pryor
it's not
and I don't know that there is an heir
to Pryor maybe Chappelle but it's not
Brendan right is that fair can I say
that without ruffling feathers and it it
doesn't mean that Brendan isn't funny on
that show right he's he's good on the
show like people like him I I I don't
I've never seen his stand-up he's a he's
a very
like
controversial figure
and
I just believe
that
there's so much drama and there's not
enough love
going around isn't that the way you feel
because
it's it's fair to say that Brendan is
new at stand-up
he's very new very new yeah and it takes
years and years to become a good
standard and sometimes it doesn't happen
sometimes it doesn't happen sometimes
the diet doesn't work a lot of people
die fat
you see
the things we want aren't always the
things we get
I love a tea nobody pronounces a t get
why don't we do that
now
Brendan may go on to be the greatest
comedian that has ever lived
that is a possibility I do not know that
but I don't know that it's fair
to say that he's got a goon squad
running around and intimidating people
but maybe he does
but I don't know that that's the case
but when Bobby Lee says they
the people and it's ominous
but there could be I don't know it's not
my experience with him Brendan has been
overwhelmingly nice to me he's never
made an inappropriate pass at me
and
that shows tremendous amount of
restraint on his part I have missed this
Scandal completely I am I spend most of
my time with Venture capitalists
entrepreneurs philanthropists I don't
spend a lot of time with comedians
because they're stupid and poor
that's the only reason I don't spend
time with them because they are dumb and
they don't have means which makes it
very tough
and Brennan's rich I guess he is he
seems Rich seems to have money and
Bobby's kind of Rich too but I don't
spend time with any of these people
because I don't really want to and it's
not a knock on them they're colleagues
right
I've never done tigerbelly I've been
asked a few times we had to reschedule
I just I don't care about doing other
people's shows anymore I just want to do
my own
I just hope everyone finds a pathway to
love
because it's not overrated
it isn't
find a pathway to love God damn it
what's life really about fighting all of
this silliness his craziness who tried
to throw whose wife into the car it's
not a big deal why do we got to keep
going over this
people are so fast and loose with the
truth
so that's my statement I'm agnostic but
I have to cover it it's the news the
same way I have to cover Roe v Wade I'm
unaffected by Roe v Wade
I haven't had an abortion in a year
but I gotta cover it
because you know this country's headed
towards a uh
a real crazy Christian
theocracy
or
a like San Francisco Style
improv theater
either one makes me unhappy
I very much want a cold somewhat
emotionless bureaucratic
state
Curtis yarvin's not wrong about all
these things you know I don't love the
idea of just one centralized Authority
but his idea that things have to be sort
of cold and somewhat bureaucratic and
boring I find
uh I don't know
better than this current Hot Blooded
scream Fest where all the values are on
the table all the time and all the
people have to fight
and I just I hope the best for Brandon
and Bobby and Annie and Khalil I've
never met any of these people
I've never met any of them I'm too rich
I don't know
stand Up's a weird thing
and I know that Brandy gets a lot of
hate because a lot of people feel that
he when people get in to stand up later
in life
uh
and are not good at it it bothers people
but he's trying very hard and I'm sure
he's gotten better
and you know listen
again
I think the guy he's making a buck he's
making more than a buck right he's
making a little change
is he going to win the Mark Twain Prize
for humor
probably not
but that's okay
stand-ups just been polluted by garbage
for years
there's nothing like the feeling of
getting outside to run hide hike or just
be somewhere we feel the most ourselves
every man Jack put that experience in a
bottom their men's care products feature
naturally derived ingredients outdoor
inspired scents and reasonable packaging
responsible packaging so you can get the
inspiration of The Great Outdoors
wherever you roam this really drives the
women crazy or the men whatever you want
it's great everybody likes somebody to
smell like a hot lager and we spend a
lot of time thinking about what we put
in our bodies but what you put on your
body is just as important the Neo green
goop being sold he was body wash is
anything but natural or clean besides if
you need a PhD to pronounce all of the
different ingredients it's not for you
every man Jack's care products use the
best ingredients Nature has to offer
your skin will thank you we just started
using it I love it I love the product
they sent me the sandalwood scent is my
favorite for the body wash and shampoo
I'm telling you right now I am telling
you every man Jack has it all body wash
deodorant skin care products shampoos
bombs oils to tame and nourish your hair
and beard make every day feel like a
getaway with Incredible sense inspired
by The Great Outdoors I love Cedarwood
it's when we go to Nobu and they burn
the cedar it's one of my favorites
smells I want to smell like Cedarwood
sea salt Citrus every man Jack Works
exceptionally without any of the harsh
chemicals what's your favorite every
Manchester at probably the sea salt you
know my wife uh only uses naturally
derived ingredients this is approved by
her she loves it she loves the way it
smells like I've been using this since
they sent it to me every man Jack Works
exceptionally without any of the harsh
chemicals like parabens and dyes it can
be abrasive to your skin and leave it
feeling dry they use many clean
naturally derived ingredients as
possible like activated charcoal
caffeine green tea coconut oil shea
butter trust us you'll feel the
difference whether it's hydrating body
wash nourishing beer butter or
thickening shampoo and conditioner every
product goes above and beyond needs
something else to feel good about here's
three every minute Jack uses responsibly
made packaging they're a natural Forest
Foundation partner and their products
are cruelty free
head to everymanjack.com and get 20 off
your first purchase with the code Dylan
d-i-l-l-o-n remember when you support
these companies you support our show it
enables us to do the type of content you
guys love so if you go to
everymanjack.com to get 20 off your
first purchase with the code Dylan
d-i-l-l-o-n
Talent is with us he's written the
foremost book on stand up
what do you think about
this this phenomenon we have we're MMA
people or whoever they happen to be are
doing comedy and and people are upset
about it they're angry I stand with
Brendan
I stand with the guy who could uh do the
most physical damage to me and that's
Brendan in this case
I fear him not because of Any
allegations just to how good he is with
his hands and his feet uh so yeah
Brendan I'm with you brother I kind of
like him
me too yeah I do it's it's here's the
thing
I'm supposed to hate him which makes me
like him yeah right yeah totally
I mean he's always been a gentleman to
me
truly yeah he's always been lovely to me
you know and I I think that
to to be diplomatic about it
you know when it gets to the men woman
stuff
and the boys and the girls and the
parking lots and the cars and who owns a
pickup truck who doesn't own a pickup
truck yeah who's going where and who
goosed me in the hall I try not to get
involved it's none of my business
well you're above it you don't need it
well
I do need a goosing
that's that's actually
it's actually untrue I'm not above a
goosing and I need a good thing
and I'm gonna say this if Brandon Schaub
threw me against the wall of The Comedy
Store and started to make out with me
I'd just shut up about it
I wouldn't run my mouth all over town
and I'm not saying he did that to anyone
I don't even think that's being alleged
but I'm saying that if if Brandon Schaub
raped me I mean violently if Brandon
grabbed me and raped to the point where
I was worried about my own uh innards
if he raped me I mean took my head and
and I mean I've bitten a pillow before
and that's a shock to no one but I mean
biting it where it's permanently damaged
saliva flowing out of my mouth in an
uncomfortable way
I could smell the blood
if he destroyed my [ __ ] to the point
where I couldn't [ __ ] for weeks or [ __ ]
too much
whatever the problem was if if Brandon
[ __ ] me to the point where I had to
see a doctor and the Doctor's first
response was what happened to you
if my bedroom looked like the first 48
with blood and [ __ ] all over
if my bedroom looked like a murder scene
and again if it was non-consensual
I would keep my mouth shut
because I want the focus to be on the
work
I want the focus to be on the work
I don't want people looking at me and
going oh that's the comic Brendan anally
raped
foreign
I want the focus to be on the work
now
I just think I don't know but this
mention of goons and they and them and
they're coming and
it's people I don't know I like Bobby
too I mean you know
I did dinner with him I didn't love when
I moved to Austin and he was like you
owe the comedy store so much why would
you turn your back on La I'm like what
are you talking about
the only reason I got pastors because
Joe Rogan ordered them to pass me that's
the way things work I didn't develop the
[ __ ] Comedy Store I don't care what
happens to The Comedy Store I don't care
what happened to the comedy seller yes
they're great places to work they're
great institutions and and I have
friends that work there and I work at
the store and I'm very happy that I'm
able to work at the store it's a big
moment in my career to get past at the
comedy store but make no mistake the
reason I got past was because Joe Rogan
made a phone call
so I don't romanticize this so I had a
dinner with Bobby and I didn't love that
me spade and Bobby had a dinner and
Bobby's kind of like don't you feel like
you got inducted into the mafia and now
you're like turning your back on the ma
and I'm like what are you what do you
what are you even saying with your mouth
I didn't love I mean me and him are not
friendly but I mean we're friends-ish
I see him he's funny he's a colleague I
respect him
what Sam what are you pointing out is it
an animal it was it one of those
pendulums yeah they're all over now
these fat little rats
Ben was telling me a fun story about
Bobby Lee
what about it Ben did he rape you no
no I was just I was just mentioning
offhand to Sam that I believe he shows
his [ __ ] on stage I've heard is that
that's what you were talking about right
Sam not the other thing yeah yeah that's
right and that's fun
good for him
I just don't understand the beef and the
drama and the anger and the hatred all I
would like is love Pathways to love and
healing
that's all I want for everyone involved
but I don't care about any of them
do you understand what I mean yeah of
course but that's the isn't that that's
I feel like the most honest way to put
it I don't care about any of them right
but I would I hope they're okay if you
were to say that you're deeply affected
by all this I'm unaffected I'm really
uneffective you're in the rainforest I'm
unaffected and I don't care I'm in a
rain forest
it doesn't matter to me I don't care
who did what to whom and how allegedly
allegedly allegedly it doesn't mean
anything to me
but everybody's like what do you think
about this I'm getting calls from the
states
what do you think weigh in
I just personally
no
that if I was brutally raped
by Brandon shout even if it wasn't rape
it was just rough stuff
if he was heavy-handed
well I imagine that it would be
I believe it would be the type of rape
that I consented to
sent to rape
that's another thing people don't
realize
like for example
maybe he cornered me and said hey do you
want to get raped and I was like yeah
maybe and I felt threatened and scared
and then I drove him to my apartment
and opened the door
and allowed him to re or maybe I was so
traumatized I instructed or forced him
to rape me
somehow I don't know but if I was uh
brutally raped
brutally and viciously raped I would
probably keep my mouth shut because I'd
want people to focus on the work and
isn't that the problem in the business
because people are just living in
bubbles of fear
and it's wrong but I don't care about
this or anyone involved
I hope I've covered it to everyone's
satisfaction I'm not friends with anyone
involved I like Annie Letterman I'm
friends with her
but it's what it is here right it is
what it is I hope everyone's respected
and that's what it is
yeah
maybe it wouldn't have happened if they
all moved to Austin Texas
how about that
because everything is love in Austin
Texas we have a thriving economy of back
alley abortions
and shootings
but that's my statement
I'm going on the record Fearless
unafraid
I just have to get that out there
putting it out there my official
statement on this is I do not care about
anyone involved
and I really don't know what happened I
don't want to find out it doesn't matter
to me
at all when I go to The Comedy Store and
I stand in the parking lot and people
talk to me I want to kill myself
done
I've never had less fun than when I'm
doing that in that place I have
zero opinion on this and I really don't
care about anything no shade to the
store it's a great [ __ ] room but I
just don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care
and uh
that's all I'm saying and I hope that
foreign
I hope that people
take that and and love life
I I'm very upset
about the experience that I'm having
right now
at the end of my stay in Australia which
has been largely positive
the audience is we brought Sam out here
at the end he did two shows one really
good one I mean
fine
the audience has been largely they've
been really amazing Aussies are great
audiences because comedy is for drunk
people who don't overthink things so
guess what
there is a plethora of that here
a friend of mine is losing his hair but
then he started keeps and I'm telling
him he's had great success keeps his
grade it offers a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your hair via
convenient virtual doctors consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home 24 7 care and
support they have a network of great
medical advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality this is very
low cost okay I'm telling you two out of
three men are going to experience some
form of male pattern baldness in their
lifetime you want to get ahead of that
and the only way to really get ahead of
it without wigs and dies and all that
crazy stuff is to keep the hair that you
have on your head right now so you have
to start and keeps takes these FDA
approved uh ingredients and offers you
the generic so you save a lot of money
prevention is key here treatments can
take four to six months to see results
so act fast when it comes to your hair
save more spend less if you were ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dillon to get
your first month free
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dillon and we
know plenty of people that have used
this and it works this is a ton of our
friends are bald and that it is really
working for them yeah yeah
I love raycon earbuds they are so much
cheaper than the earbuds that you know
what we're talking about that everybody
else has they are a must-have okay they
are great if you're multitasking and you
want to keep your hands free with
raycons they can people can stay
entertained listening to their favorite
podcast music they can take phone calls
with Vivid voice technology all hands
free okay they come in a bunch of fun
color options you can find Mom something
that suits her personality and style
what a great Mother's Day gift from Mom
on the go raycons offers eight hours of
play time in a 32 hour battery life with
a complicated portable charging case
they are priced just right you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio Brands and Ray Conn's
everyday earbuds have over forty nine
thousand five star reviews perfectly
fitting for a five-star Mom I'm telling
you
I love my mother and I'm going to buy
her raycon earbuds so she can hear
crystal clear my phone calls with her
when I call her she loves music she
loves podcast and she can enjoy all of
that for eight hours at a time with
raycon I'm telling you they are a great
supporter of the Tim Dylan show so go to
buy raycon.com Tim to get 15 off your
Mother's Day order that's by raycon.com
Tim to get 15 off your Mother's Day
order that's by raycon.com Tim I use
these headphones I love them they're
they're much better than the alternative
they are inexpensive and they're better
quality
I said to myself we are in Australia
let's go see a part of it for a few days
before we leave I did a cursory amount
of research not a lot and I booked
myself uh the perpetually ungrateful
Benjamin and the always grateful and
Lovely Sam Talent uh the room the finest
room at the and I don't want to hurt
anyone's business here but the silky
Oaks Lodge and the daintree rainforest
okay we got the Pavilion Suite which is
I believe seven thousand a night
Australia maybe five thousand or fifty
three hundred a night American okay
three nights a fifteen thousand dollar
commitment the room is nice we're in the
rainforest it is a private pool I have
no beef with the room
but
let's talk a little bit about the staff
I want to mention a woman named Lauren
first because I want to say to the
people that will this will eventually
get to uh the uh people at the uh
silky Forest shed and they will hear
this
and they will hear it because someone
will tell them it may be tomorrow it may
be in three months someone will go
remember the fat guy
well he talked about us on this thing
they could also be listening to it right
now because their dorms are behind us
well good but they'll be like remember
him
he's got a podcast and then they're
gonna go what's a podcast
there you go with slot radio but on the
computer
what's a computer it's where you get to
porn
and
I want to simulate this woman who is a
lovely woman
she is a waitress
she's uh coming up here and she was
phenomenal the only reason I am not
burning this place down
is because of this woman who I thought
did a phenomenal job serving some of the
worst Food I've had in my life foreign
trying to put a happy face and and you
know bless these people here they're
children of God but they just you know
they say it's Gourmet and it's fine
dining I mean it's really it's a
nightmare there was no reason for the
food to be as bad as it is they don't
have any room service
you can't get any room service you've
got to go to the goddamn Lodge
the other problem is there are
activities in this area that will all
kill you
there are jellyfish the size of a penny
that can kill you there are large
jellyfish there are saltwater crocodiles
there are sharks there is the glimpy
glimpy a tree that if you brush into it
send shards of glass through your system
uh there are platypuses everything can
kill you and of course they will
encourage you to do these activities and
as soon as you Google them you realize
how deadly they are but these people
obviously the tourism industry will not
survive here the small tourism industry
that there is I mean people want to
snorkel the Great Barrier Reef which I
wanted to do but I realize it's not
worth dying for because the reef is like
half bleached anyway that shit's over
and they give you these Stinger suits we
talked about it on the patreon
being a bigger person and trying to like
squeeze into a stinger suit it's like
just let me die and these Stinger suits
are supposed to protect you from the uh
Jellyfish but a lot of them don't even
do that
but you know because of the tourism
industry they they just you know people
die here and people get hospitalized
pretty frequently but they just kind of
ignore it and they go hey it is what it
is I get it I understand it's like
certain uh you know if you go into
Chicago and you go hey is it safe they
go yeah it's great come on in
sure you could be walking down the
Miracle Mile and you could uh get uh
descended upon by a gang of teenagers
that beats living [ __ ] out of you in
front of your wife completely
emasculates you but they're not going to
tell you that if you call the peninsula
and this ain't the peninsula but my
point is that mum's the word on the
deaths
here can you bring up the article about
the zip line Ben yeah I got it right
here so Widow Sue's daintree zipline
company Engineers for Millions after
husband Falls to death this is a
September of 2021.
uh so the wife of a man who died after
plunging from a zip line in Far North
Queensland has launched a multi-million
dollar lawsuit against those she holds
responsible
Adelaide father of three dean Sanderson
50 died after the zip line he was
attached to failed while high above the
daintree rainforest in October 2019. his
wife Shannon who was in a separate
harness but launched at the same time
also fell approximately 10 meters at the
jungle Surf and Canopy Tours and
survived despite serious injuries now I
read another article about this and the
people that were on the zipline line
said it was crazy because the zip line
went out and then there was just the
sound of the zip line coming back
without a person oh God and then they
just heard the wife and they said it was
a blood curdling scream she's laying on
the floor of the uh jungle going
yeah it says the twang when the zipline
came back up made an awful noise then
there was just silence for what seemed
like forever well you know who's
responsible for that truly
if you think about it Brandon chaub
what I'm saying here is that it's a
deadly environment we went to one of the
most remote locations of the World Cape
tribulation
I mean as Ben said in one of his rare
lucid and meaningful uh thoughts that it
was
um what did you say about like a beach
from Robinson Caruso like the idyllic
image oh I said it's a platonic ideal of
a beach like it could only exist inside
your own mind and then you step into it
it's such a surreal experience it is
surreal it is surreal you're welcome
it's so beautiful you can't see it yes
it is surreal you're welcome now
you also saw one of the little animals
you like today and powder melon uh
they changed the pronunciation of it
maybe it's a put a melon and you also
saw what do you call it uh and uh the
porcupine it's basically a porcupine
yeah but it lays eggs the glazed eggs do
I ever get tired from making people's
dreams come true fair question
the answer is no I'm into fatigable but
this beach you can't swim because
there's Crocs and jellies and they'll
kill you and at night there's wild boar
and then if you make it through all of
that there are grifters living in the
woods I don't mean grifters in the sense
that they have shows on The Daily wire I
mean like they're people that live in
tents in the woods
that are will kill you if the Flora and
the fauna and everything else doesn't
kill you yeah last chance hobos last
chance of us so but it is stunningly
beautiful Land Before Time prehistoric
[ __ ] there's crocodile infested Rivers
it is cool to be in a place that is
deadly
uh that being said to do any of these
things I love freedom and I hate rules
and we are in a nanny State and that is
baked into the bones of every human
being that walks this continent they
like rules and they want everything to
be done for them they like things
planned for them they like knowing when
they should eat how they should eat
where they should go what's the approved
boat the approved tour we left the tour
we walked off a tour because we were
driven and by the way they like to book
everything through this Resort
they want to book it they want to get
the Kickbacks okay so as soon as you
walk in first of all as soon as you walk
in they start asking you what your
flight number is when you're leaving so
that they can get Transportation because
this is remote as [ __ ] we tried to get a
car into town to get better cigar you
can't even get a car into town so as
soon as you walk in here they're like
here's the plan here's breakfast here's
lunch here's dinner here's the tour
you're going to go on and I'm like hey
man and and when are you leaving and I'm
like hey slow the [ __ ] down here I just
like freedom I like to relax there's
nothing relaxing about rules
there's no in-room dining you can't just
go yeah I'm just chilling maybe I'll
order a burger to the room there's none
of that as you show up for a formal
dinner of [ __ ] food
and everybody who's in this area is
running from something and this is we
bribe the local woman who didn't have a
driver's license to drive us around
lovely woman named uh what's her name
Zona Zona and uh
she was a lovely woman and she told us
that people are running they owe their
wives money their their their uh they're
on the run from the law and you see it
in the waitresses the faces here outside
of Lauren many of them are human
trafficking victims and they've
trafficked themselves to the four the
far north reaches of Queensland
Australia so that they can serve gruel
to these morons who buy uh you know this
[ __ ] jungle experience or whatever
the hell this thing is
it's not even
you know the wildlife you barely see it
if you see it you're dead
nature really is kind of fake when you
think about it like you don't you rarely
see it you know so the whole thing from
stem to stern
unenjoyable and the faces on these
miserable people these miserable people
that for whatever reason have been
exiled from society and are forced to
get your flight number what do you want
the tail number in the chat like they're
so in your business when so we went out
with this uh local lovely woman and she
took us around and we come back in and
one of these squawking Birds was like
where have you been
I'm like what are You My Mother what do
you mean where have I been you bird
I've been where I want to be it's a
[ __ ] vacation but they're crims
criminals they call them crams and what
that means is that if you give the
people on this continent even the most
cursory amount of freedom
they remember that their lineage is as
you brilliantly said horse thieves Pig
[ __ ] Pig [ __ ] Farmers sheep
thieves these are criminals they cannot
be allotted any freedom even when you go
on a vacation there's no Freedom none it
is a prison colony and this Resort is a
prison I have been in a prison it is not
at all what you would consider luxurious
it is a prison it's a gilded cage it's a
gilded cage where they are in your
business and they're in your face and
all they want to know is what you're
doing who you're doing it with how it
was all they try to do is get in your
[ __ ] business well I don't want a
mommy and a daddy
I just want you to be and they said
leave a comment card
I'm writing on the common cart hey I
have one of the top podcasts in America
you can listen to my review of your
Resort if you can get Wi-Fi which is
horrible here
am I wrong about this Sam I mean you're
here am I am I overstating it I mean you
let you lend yourself to comedic
hyperbole typically but no this is valid
and Justified they've been keeping tabs
on us when you're paying fifteen
thousand dollars uh for three days to be
here yeah they're all over us the woman
who's been serving us food before we got
Lauren was dead-eyed bleached out well
it's sticky fingers Karen well that's
not even care I'm talking about the
woman who wouldn't make eye contact
influence
Karen's fine she was lovely but I
believe she's probably here because she
had a little problem with the credit
cards oh yeah and she she liked to get
credit cards that weren't her own
you can see
in their eyes that they're thieves
criminals
you could see the lineage in their eyes
but they're not clever enough to pull
off any Grand schemes or heists so now
they're here not getting tipped and we
had to walk off a tour because we had
this guy
uh
and he started the tour but we we go to
some little like Rec Center okay and
he's locked you see this is what
governments can do when they really put
them on to it we've treated the
indigenous people very poorly but now
we've got this rec center for them and
then he's like there's a lot more white
trashed and black trash in Australia he
says I don't know about America I don't
know if you have racial problems over
there it's like of course we do and you
do know that sir as limited as you are
you do know that we have racial problems
and why are we talking about genocide at
8 A.M to show me uh what is it a powder
melon a powder melon just show me a
Patty melon the large rat I don't want
to hear about the genocide it's eight in
the [ __ ] morning we hadn't had coffee
yet yeah we haven't had coffee I don't
want to do the displacement of an entire
group of people then he goes there's
going to be an indigenous ceremony
I'm like wait a minute why are we a part
of it with three white dudes what are
you talking about you're and and then
Kona Zona Zona she told us she's like
yeah it's just like a smoke ceremony and
it's like you so it's a [ __ ]
ceremony they make like indigenous
people do and like all these white
[ __ ] tourists come in here
and just have to like stay there I'm
like hey man I don't need them dancing
and putting on a show for me if they
want to do like a cool indigenous
ceremony or if they want to address the
Brandon Chow Bobby Lee issue and they
want to like somehow heal the comedy
community with communing with the spirit
that's fine but I don't need some type
of show so we had to leave the tri and
you knew it was happening as soon as we
got on this bus with other people as
soon as the doors opened I saw there was
other people in there wearing shorts and
Safari hats and I was like counting down
in my head so how long will we make it
on this first stop second stop and then
as soon as I shut the door I felt the
group chat buzz in my pocket and I knew
we were getting off immediately because
I I number one I wanted a private tour
I'm not trying to be on there with other
idiots that got duped into this right
number two they were they were the they
were the Australian Disney couples they
were sexless people yeah yes they were
sexless and
it was worse than that it was that they
really wanted to learn something but
they
they didn't but they did I hate people
that want to go on a vacation it's like
read a goddamn book what are you gonna
learn in eight minutes
what are you gonna learn on a half a day
tour about what really happened here
like can you can you stop I hate and
like when this guy this [ __ ] Mick
God I hope he hears it when he talked
the people in the bus were like they had
Stern faces and they were like nodding
and the it was very grave and they were
like we're taking it seriously
we understand how hard it's been
any Star and I'm like you know what man
this is just not my vibe so we had to
peace out I'm like sorry sir we're
supposed to be at the great uh Barrier
Reef smoking cigarettes it was a very
solemn Affair but he was also doing his
sticky tour bus driver jokes
it's the worst I was a tour guide tour
guides are damned people they're damned
they're forced to be
a visitor in the place that they live
constantly it's a constant Groundhog Day
movie where every day is the same the
people come and go tour guides are
forced to be Spectators they are damned
I was one of them but I was doing comedy
at night so I know what it's like and
that hacky shtick they all do was so
it's so sad when a tour guide throws out
a joke that bombs you wish for his own
sake that he just blows his brains out
in front of you you want to see brain
matter splatter on the windshield of
that van after one of those hacky jokes
doesn't land
because it's so sad when they do that
and then he tries to sound morally
Superior yeah that's the issue is when
he's like we was a genocide and we stole
the babies and fed him to dingoes yeah
didgerid don't ask me about it and now
we have a community center
it's a community center
I mean Ben what are your so I I just I
mean what are your I just did it I mean
what do you
do you think about these things so
remember he he was and that's true but
the other thing I think
about it no I'm kidding Go on Ben the
perpetually ungrateful Ben Avery World
traveler just doesn't care go on so that
remember how he uh told us the K's are
pronounced with a G so I looked this up
they're the gugu yulanji this was the
group that was here that was supposedly
uh you know taken over right I did some
digging uh turns out uh the gugu yulanji
uh hunted Chinese for cannibalistic
feasting so they would eat people so I
wonder if he goes into that on the tour
at all well I wish I knew that this is
why you gotta Google before we go on the
tour because I would have said hey Mick
I heard that they used to hunt Chinese
people and eat them
and I'm not even I don't even know if
I'm against that I'm just saying if
we're gonna have a fact-finding mission
at eight o'clock in the morning
that's what shob's gonna do with Bobby
[Laughter]
there's now where did you find this out
Ben are you on one of those sites you go
on no I went to Wikipedia and then went
to a separate article and they said that
they uh hunted the Chinese and ate them
uh yeah so modern historians now
consider that these early reports like
the tales of the cuckoo ilanji hunting
Chinese for cannibalistic feasting
whatever partial truth they contain
functions to a sewage sorry
not a sewage any guilt European settlers
may have felt for their key role in the
dissemination of Northern Queensland
Aboriginal communities so that is a
disputed thing I don't want to disparage
the uh the good people here but I mean
in this instance what does Chinese
person mean
good questions
just tried the Lululemon
what did they I think a lot of these the
Lululemon
maybe ate a few Chinese people but
did they deserve to have their land
taken so that they could build this [ __ ]
hotel and get my business and serve me
[ __ ] food and charge me an arm and a leg
so that they can run around like a Stasi
wanting to know where I am at every
moment of the [ __ ] day
I'd rather be here eating Chinese babies
with the Lululemon
I mean they even have to qualify it
they're they're dismissing it but they
also have to qualify it saying whatever
partial truth that continues here's the
deal folks white people are horrifically
violent but if you think that natives
were all it was all like sunshine and
happy songs it's not the case there were
tribes it was Warfare there was violence
there was pillaging there was conquering
there was cannibalism
I mean violence is not the Providence
only of white European settlers it was
really the the currency of the world I
mean people that have an ignorance of
history or that only subtle the study
the colonial era and they don't look
back at ancient history they don't know
anything about Antiquity they don't know
anything about
you know they they get a very skewed
view of the world and they tend to
demonize Western civilization that has a
Litany of problems and like every
civilization was built on oppression
plundering killing murdering but before
that listen there's there's very few
countries that were established by
people showing up and going hey do you
mind if we get in on this that's not the
way the world worked it was a world of
conquerors and killers of diseases you
know
people have to chill the [ __ ] out yeah
Blood Meridian violence is man
that's right
men are violent people and so are women
and and you know we just got to move on
from this
it doesn't matter that they hate Chinese
children or adults it doesn't bother me
the little lemon can do whatever they
want
is there a spokesman for the Lululemon
for the kuji his book is in our bathroom
right now oh that guy I saw that I
dropped it behind the window and I can't
get it out oh yeah I tried to get at it
too when I was talking about one of the
the Elders of I think this tribe there's
a book of his Photography in our uh room
well I'm deciding with them because they
haven't been [ __ ] me for three days
serving me [ __ ] and getting in my
business so I don't care what they did I
would have rather hang out with them
there is an indigenous swimming hole
here called the Blue Hole that you're
not allowed to go in yeah and
um and uh because it's for uh the the
local women to bathe and some people did
and one guy said he was cursed and he's
now sterile
let's move on uh here because I just I
don't want to lose myself this isn't you
know a show that's going to con this
isn't I'm not a travel blogger I will be
back home next week
I just want to let everybody know
that the silky Oaks Lodge in Queensland
Australia is running a human trafficking
ring
deal with that information what you will
many people right now are having
problems with uh coming out of the
pandemic especially agoraphobics you
want to make sure your mental health and
your mental Fitness is great so better
help is huge people that realize
physical symptoms like headaches teeth
grinding and even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about Doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
overeating I have all kinds of stress
and it comes out in many different ways
stress shows up you gotta fight it and
understand your triggers understand how
to push through understand how to treat
yourself well better help is customize
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to it's more
affordable than in-person therapy give
it a try and see if online therapy can
help lower your stress I'm telling you
right now I use this you use it all of
our friends use it it and we're all
doing mentally great all of my friends
are just in a beautiful place mentally
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and Tim Dillon show listers get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com Tim
D that is b e t t e r h e l p.com slash
Tim D they're [ __ ] billionaires
they've got the inside line on
everything even inflation can't touch
them but I'm about to walk into their
eyes wide shut party and start pulling
off masks because I know their secret
Picasso Basquiat Banksy lots of these
[ __ ] are invest in Mad amounts
of Contemporary Art why how about 36
average historical price appreciation
when inflation is at three percent or
outpacing the average total return of
the freaking S P 500 for the last 25
years now there's someone who can beat
them at their own game who's making
their this art available to people like
us I'm talking about Masterworks I've
mentioned before how I think this idea
is genius and you guys seem to agree so
I use my massive swinging
influence to get all my listeners uh
Priority Access to skip their wait list
just go to masterworks.art Tim that's
masterworks.art Tim and I'm telling you
right now investing in these pieces of
art you don't have to have a hundred
million dollars anymore all you all you
have to do is have a Wi-Fi connection
and a little bit of money and
intelligence because you can go in there
buy a percentage of one of these amazing
paintings and see your money safely
appreciate while it is tied up in one of
the great Commodities of our time art go
to masterworks.art Tim that's
masterworks.org Tim and see important
regulations and disclosures at
masterworks.io CD that's masterworks.io
CD remember go to masterworks.art Tim
and think about how to protect your
money and watch it grow using
Timeless pieces of art Roe v Wade that
is in the news Roe v Wade
the Supreme Court potentially
overturning Roe v Wade
the federal protections for abortion
going to be eliminated States like Texas
maybe Louisiana places like that
criminalizing abortion potentially
making it uh felony perhaps are we
headed backwards towards the Dark Ages
yes however
you know here's the point that needs to
be made
there's got to be a period of time
between conception and birth where an
abortion is legal after a certain amount
of time it is cruel inhuman and it is
murder you can't have an abortion at
eight months well right
may I yes okay because now you're going
to say
if the mother's life is in danger no I'm
not
you're going to say
okay well what are you going to say I'm
going to say that usually when it's a
very late term abortion yeah it's one of
two things that's either the fact that
they've do a scan on the baby and it's
not developing the way they thought it
would and it's not going to be born with
a heart or it doesn't have a head it's
some very gross mutation that will not
allow the child to live outside the the
utero or it when it gets into a sixth or
seventh month it's because there's
certain places in the country where you
need to be
you have to wait two weeks to get it all
done and then you work at Arby's and you
have to get to Abilene Texas from
Houston I understand but that to me
doesn't matter if you have a seven month
baby inside of you I don't care how long
it's taking you to find out that you're
pregnant I don't care that you had to go
from Arby's to Abilene which I imagine
they have and Arby's in Avalanches they
do yeah actually you had problem there
right you cannot eliminate a a full I
mean seven months kids are born at seven
months and live happy lives that's a
fully formed fetus are you saying that
you should be able to eliminate a seven
month pregnancy I'm just saying that a
lot of these instances are just a matter
of I get the heart thing I get it baby
can't live outside right I get that but
what I don't get is like hey man I
didn't have the time yeah I don't get
that I think 99 of the cases it's born
with a foot for a brain so they have to
kill it before it comes out because it
won't live outside but there are these
instances of women people would feed for
brains that live in mansions
but I get what you're saying yeah I'm
not trying to be insensitive to the
plight of
a mother
that is struggling with the fact that
the child will not be able to survive
but I don't think you could just say
it's seven months hey they have Down
syndrome let's let's flush it
and I'm not defending either way I'm
just saying these are the reasons people
have uh have late term abortions I
understand because I'm already going to
get my whole ripped open
from even weighing in on it so no no no
no well you gotta weigh in this is the
way it's the way of the world I'm saying
that
in Europe and in the UK in most places
I don't know how long it is
but it's usually Ben can you look up
the UK abortions the vast majority of
them are before 20 weeks I don't know
what or 25 we I'm unsure this is not an
area that I've done a hell of a lot of
research no I'm not an expert in third
trimester and I believe that abortion
should be legal in America
and federally legal like I I don't
believe because I think that it just
hurts poor women
that have to make all these arrangements
to go to another state and have an
abortion this is I don't believe in
returning here to the Dark Ages that's
not it's not good well the great state
of Colorado made it a constitutional
protected right well I think New York
did too I mean there's some
you know but I I also
believe that after a certain point
it's tough to make the moral argument
uh so like nine out of ten abortions are
done before 12 weeks in most high come
High income countries so I'm assuming
that falls within the UK would be that
so 9 out of ten done before 12 weeks
which would be what's three months
keep it under three ladies
that's all
what
I mean Sam you give me a face I'm trying
to come up with a compromise here the
world's not gonna be [ __ ] Denver so
we need to have a compromise like we
can't just I have to be the the voice of
reason I believe in legal Federal
abortion rights but I also believe that
you can't like six months into a
pregnancy
go hey this ain't for me I don't believe
that
it's that's a baby
at three months it's not a bait so hey
ladies okay so hey ladies when you're
out there for ladies night
just keep it under three months please
I I found out many of those states are
gonna Outlaw the pill too so I mean
we're really going to the Dark Age but
this is the pushback against genders not
real and all this other stuff that's
happening where you have this
encroaching Madness that you're seeing
all over the place people are going to
you know they're going to deeply
entrench themselves in like you know
like Theocratic
Christianity where they go well now we
have to live in a theocracy which is not
the answer either because a lot of
people
that don't subscribe to Christianity but
I'm just saying morally in a humanist
way six months you can't start
you know we can't do this well they're
still going to have the abortions
they're just going to pass away from
getting shoddy work done well if you're
going to have an abortion at seven
months when you have a fully formed baby
those are fun women though those are the
ones who get Knocked Up they they kind
of well you know this isn't for me I
want to go to Cabo yeah we're going to
lose the fun women see that's when I
have a little bit of an issue with it
because
I I think there should be a happy medium
in this country between
ending all abortion and allowing people
at eight months who go you know maybe
this isn't for me
to flush the baby there's got to be a
happy medium and it's ladies let's keep
it under three
keep it under three months well you
don't know you're pregnant until well
pay attention
attention to your body
If I Was Pregnant I'd know
I have a medical paper here from England
and Wales uh hey good job so here are
the major reasons for having an abortion
after 13 plus weeks of gestation can I
can I I complimented you
and you don't even you don't even say
thank you well it was condescending why
was it condescending the tone was
condescending how was it condescending
because you were implying that I
typically don't do my job
that's a very negative way to look at it
I said good job you then believed that I
was being condescending
do you have guilt that you don't do a
good job are you guilty uh I mean I have
feelings of like worthlessness and I
guess I feel guilty yeah but those are
your feelings not my feeling you asked
me how I feel though right but I don't
make you feel that way do I why are you
making about you you ask me how I feel
yes
yes a job I'm trying to compliment you
and you are wrapping up your own
self-concept in it or all I do is try to
do the right thing by not only you but
every man woman non-binary person child
elderly ancient Elder indigenous person
and guardian of the land that I've
always just try to
do the right thing so I just say good
job that's all I'm saying I'm saying
is it condesa does it sound
condescending when I say good job
does that really sound condescending
yeah I think you have internal guilt
that you are racked with because perhaps
you feel
that
you are not worthy of the compliments
that I give but that is not my fault
I want you to look in the mirror and
give yourself a big kiss
okay okay now please tell us about that
medical paper from Wales and England
good uh so here are the reasons that
you're looking for in terms of why
people have abortions after 13 weeks of
gestation yes their hoes so uh at the
top of the list is the top ten list like
Letterman yeah you do it like Letterman
number 10.
so uh 41 of people said I was not sure
about having the abortion and it took me
a while to make my mind up and ask for
one not good not not a credible answer
move on it's not uh second is uh here's
38 percent of people say I didn't
realize I was pregnant earlier because
my periods are irregular that is more
understandable
that is a lot more understandable than
hey it's six months in and I you know
I'm still on the fence on inappropriate
what about 13 weeks though fine is that
under three
uh that's one more than that would be
one that'd be three weeks in them three
months in a week yeah fine just
just uh the number is three
so then we have uh let's see here
oh this was out of this isn't
percentages this is out of a 858 uh
people so that was 41 people and then
38. now 36 and I'm going down in the
majorities here 36 people said I thought
the pregnancy was much less advanced
than it was when I asked for the
abortion
hmm okay um wait what it says I thought
the pregnancy was much less advanced
than it was when I asked for the
abortion they thought they were one
month and they were really at four I
believe so yeah okay all right uh 32
people say uh I wasn't sure what I would
do if I were pregnant
that's coming in at number four number
five I didn't realize I was pregnant
earlier because I was using
contraception so they assume because
they're using uh the ring thing or
they're on the pill they're not getting
their period Fair uh 30 people say I
suspected I was pregnant but I didn't do
anything about it until weeks had gone
by
okay uh 26 people said I was worried how
my parents would react
24 people said I had to wait more than
five days before I could get a
consultation appointment to get the go
ahead for the abortion and the number
one reason that people have late term
abortions
is I found out Brendan Shaw was the
father
and Paul Shane from the band stuck out
yeah
man yeah so I got more reasons here you
want to hear them yeah I got like five
more okay uh so one person says uh so 23
people say my relationship with my
partner broke down slash changed so not
good high stress you're pregnant and you
realize you don't want to go through
with it yeah these are all not okay then
22 people say I was worried about what
was involved in having an abortion so it
took me a while to ask for one so they
were scared okay but still get it under
ladies under three uh then we have uh
someone's uh 20 people say I uh I had to
wait more than seven days between
how about I give you four
four months
at four months that's still kind of a
baby you're shark tanking this thing
yeah I'm gonna give you four months
I'm gonna give you four months we gotta
make a deal nobody wants to make deals
in this country anymore let me make a
deal ladies
four months I give you four
months
but you love freedom you love your
freedom above all else I don't think you
could take an eight-month-old baby and
have an abortion that is a very
difficult thing for me morally to get
behind that is a hard thing for me
unless there is a tremendous medical
reason if you have a fully formed baby
inside of you it is very tough for me to
co-sign that to be honest I just
I mean the baby's born in a month we
should make adoption easier in this
country it is Criminal how horrible the
process is to adopt and here is the
other problem adopted kids are always
thieves yeah and untrustworthy because
they can never get over and Jana's
Papa's let me talk about this they can
never get over the feeling of
Abandonment from their mother it's baked
into their bones Russian orphanage
syndrome the way the nanny state is
baked into the bones of the Aussies and
so you are going to have a Crim for a
child
gotta you're gonna have a goddamn cream
but I still think it should be made
easier
it's difficult Ben where where do you
stand on this man the people want to
know the people want to know where
you're at how you feel weigh in
please well it seems to be like a lot of
things right uh like prostitution drugs
abortion where if you outlaw certain
things you create a whole other Litany
of problems and it doesn't necessarily
stop the the action thereof so uh I mean
to have an opinion on it it seems
somewhat pointless right because people
are going to have them no matter what
well I have to earn a living so I think
I might have to have one I don't think
it's pointless how do you pay your rent
it's completely pointless doesn't don't
you have a new car anyway
I'll tell you this
I'm running on the platform ladies let's
keep it around three please can we keep
it around three
you bunch of birds
I understand there's reasons for later
it's a case-by-case I'm just saying it
eight months you don't feel a little bad
about that Sam eight months baby's fully
formed I think this should be the last
option but I also am with Ben and the
issue that they're gonna do it anyway
you know yeah but everybody's gonna do
everything anyway people are going to do
Fentanyl anyway yeah yeah
right we outlawed fence
well I mean if you did legalize I mean
we're getting in some very murky water
if you legalize fentanyl though then
people will you know do it supervised
and it'll be easy I just mean there's so
many well are they going to do a
supervisor I love that's my favorite
argument for drug legalization where
it's like illegal is fentanyl they'll
just do it just supervise it's like will
they is that the way they're gonna do it
well all right it's Wednesday tonight's
fentanyl day I'm going for a supervised
fentanyl visit yeah it's all super fast
illegal I'll just go in I'll do Fentanyl
I'll walk out and everything's okay
um I understand what you're saying but I
do believe I mean perhaps I am further
to the right than both of you gentlemen
uh because I do believe in a little bit
of morality
I do and it's a lot of gays and gay men
specifically that are forced to kind of
kind of and you see a lot of these uh
uh gay men coming out and
saying these things that we need to have
a little bit of a moral country and it's
interesting to see because a lot of
of the more you know pansexual look out
there kind of you know people or not but
I think a lot of gay men are starting to
go listen ladies let's just can we keep
it can we just calm it down let's just
not flush it at eight and a half months
let's not do that
it should be a thing that you know we
don't do we need like there's some
people in this country I mean people
have one man shows about their abortions
it's like okay
but do we need that
do we need abortion cafes
is that next
should you be able to get an abortion in
Starbucks
with a caramel macchiato I don't know I
just think it's weird that gay men are
starting to become the moral guardians
of America now it's very weird yeah but
it's you know
I mean lesbians are hopeless they're the
vast majority of them are more suited
towards agriculture which is fine but
you know gay men right now are kind of
you know kind of you know some of us not
all of us by no means all of us probably
not even a majority
but there is a vocal minority of gay men
who are saying let's kind of keep women
in their box which I think is kind of
important
and it should be a box with velvet
where they're comfortable
but like I think gay men are the ones
who have because we're not like the
power of the [ __ ] doesn't really affect
us so we're able to say ladies how about
we calm it down
and that's important because a lot of
straight men that just want to get
pushed you're like yeah whatever flush
the babe do whatever you want
ban everything
we should only be able to use water for
a minute and a half in the shower and
gay men are going hey get your [ __ ]
away from me baby killer
[Laughter]
and
don't we need a population of people
but let's bring it back to what really
mattered Bobby Lee kalila Annie
Letterman Brendan Shout
Roe v Wade it's how we started the show
many moral questions no easy answers
no easy answers
many moral questions quandarines deep
complex important they matter I don't
know
I don't know
but I do know
and that's the horror that I live with
every day it's the struggle of being me
not knowing but also knowing well
you know
did you have you have you uh enjoyed
your time in Australia we're leaving
soon we have one more day here and then
we'll be back in our studio yeah it's a
wonderful place I mean we saw the whole
thing we really did uh six cities not
five but six that's right uh
by the way uh what was it called Point
tribulation
Cape tribulation uh three people just
died on the road there in one day on the
way up well they're drunk so it's
actually we're scared of the Crocs and
the doing any research people like flip
over those roads all the time and kill
themselves
there's no police remember and the
people aren't registered to drive yeah
maybe you do need laws
maybe you do need laws
a brilliant end
a brilliant end
it's dangerous here in the rain forest
dangerous in the comedies to a parking
lot
[Music]
danger lurks behind every door
but my consistent position
is
that I wish the best for everyone
involved
and I just don't want to see them
hear from them hear about them
at all ever for any reason
and then
we're good
as long as that promise can be made to
me
so that is my position it's my position
on everything
get away from me
and as far as the silky Oaks Lodge in uh
Mossman where the hell are we yeah uh
yeah I guess I guess so yeah you're
trying to be a grown-up Resort but you
don't know how
your nature to crims that's okay
but you need to give people Freedom you
need to fire your Chef you need to fire
most of your staff besides Lauren some
of the guys are hot
um but nobody really wants to spend this
kind of money to take a shuttle bus into
a venomous hellscape to be here served
horseshit by human Swedish human
trafficking victims
please get it the [ __ ] together because
now I have to go to the Four Seasons in
Maui and I hope Rogan hasn't booked my
[ __ ] sweet
well
anyway
for fans of comedy and MMA
those two concentric circles
for MMA fans and comedy fans this has
been the Tim Dylan show with Sam Talent
the perpetually ungrateful Ben Avery
live from Queensland Australia tomorrow
we eat at Mr Wong's in Sydney and then
the next day we're out of here and we're
coming home where the Venom lives in the
people
good night